This is a really important thing to talk about because I do have people either asking or
thinking this and they go well those people that are in the program that haven't gotten
the deal yet or those that are taking longer those that took longer like what did they
do wrong or what did they do that I can avoid and I'm going to share that so the biggest
place that I've seen people get hung up in this process is it's people that come to the table
they have other websites okay which is not a bad thing they come here maybe they're in another
program maybe they watch some YouTube videos and they built some sites okay and these sites are
sites that they never should have built and what I mean by that is there's high cost per click
there's high competition it's in the wrong niche or yada yada yada yada right so what happens is
these people that the biggest place I see people get hung up is they come in and they think you
know what I've got five sites and I'm paying this hosting and I'm getting all this and they're
like I want to say I want to take this process this flat fee process and I want to go sell
these five sites first I want to sell all five of them clear you know make sure they all have a
client and then I'm gonna build and I'm gonna go pre sell okay the reality is that if you knew
what I'm about to teach you about picking niches and picking cities and looking at cost per click
you probably wouldn't have built most of those sites okay and so what I found is that most people
that struggle and it take longer is they don't take my advice they try and take a site they never
should have built in a niche they never should have built it with cost per click that is way
too high and they try and make it work now you can sell any site I'm not saying that but if you want
to get a deal as fast as possible to start getting positive cash flow coming in I need you to listen
to me very very carefully as you are going through module one which is talking about picking the
right city and niche I want you to ask yourself this the following question if I had known what
I'm being taught right now about how to look at a niche and a city would I still have built this
site would I still have built that site would I still have built this other site okay and if
the answer is no then I don't want you spending your time trying to sell it yet I would rather
you put it on the back burner go and keep doing your SEO whatever or get rid of it because it
might not be worth it I'm not saying to get rid of all of them but I don't want you for your first
deal using this process and trying to sell that website okay down the road that's fine you have
momentum you have steam whatever you cash isn't such a thing that you know a bind that's okay but
for this this whole this very first deal what I need you to do is I need you to hear me when I
say if I had known what I'm being taught in module one which is how to pick a city in a niche
would I still have built a site if the answer is no do not choose that as your first project
instead go choose another project that you've already built maybe it's another website generating
leads or what's most often the case and I would recommend is let's go and pre-sell a deal let's
go and do this thing from start to finish where we pick the city in the niche we build the list
we build the one-pager and we do it step by step exactly as it's being taught because guys the first
deal is the most important okay and what I mean by that is they always say in sales the best time
to get a sale the best time to get a deal is after you've got the last one okay because you have
momentum so I know how this works and I need you to get your first deal because getting that first
deal is gonna open everything up it's mentally gonna open things up and allow you to get the
next one and the next one and the next one so to wrap this up the biggest place people get hung
up is they're trying to take sites they never should have built and use this process to sell
them and I'm telling you that if you wouldn't have built them after knowing what I teach you
don't spend time on them in the beginning